foreign
[Music]
for Thursday February 9th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
a day after Microsoft introduced the
world to its new artificial
intelligence-powered search engine
Google described its new AI enabled
search features here's what prabhaka
raghavan a Google senior vice president
said at the event in Paris throughout
ongoing investments in AI we can Now
understand information in its many forms
from language
to images and videos even the real world
with this deeper understanding we are
moving beyond the traditional notion of
search to help you make sense of
information in new ways but investors
didn't seem to be swayed by it shares of
Google's parent company alphabet closed
down 7.4 on Wednesday so what did Google
demonstrate and how is this leader in
Search and AI development coping with
the competition
our European Tech reporter Sam schechner
joins us from Paris Hi Sam thanks for
coming back on the show thanks for
having me so Google held this event in
Paris on Wednesday can you tell us what
they were showing off what did they
announce well it was an event that
Google's big Paris headquarters and they
announced a series of more incremental
additions to Google search and maps and
translate that they base on AI as well
as giving a little bit more detail about
some announcements they made earlier
this week about chat GPT style chat bot
called Bard and a new kind of Google
search result that will use generative
AI the technology behind chat GPT
to give you answers to complex questions
and I think it's that latter part that
people were most looking for and and
that certainly I was most interested in
hearing about
so you were there at the event what was
it like I mean was it revolutionary did
it show you anything you didn't expect
they showed some pretty cool little
features some of which they teased
before about how you can walk down the
street while holding Google Maps up and
it'll identify what the places of
business are in front of you if they
weren't already labeled in real life
through augmented reality and they
talked about how they think generative
AI can help answer questions that have
no one right answer which is a problem
that search results face they want to
put the one right answer at the top of
the results page but in general I think
people in the room who are asking
questions maybe were a little
unsatisfied with the level of detail
about how this would compare to chat GPT
how this would compare to what Microsoft
announced with its integration with chat
GPT and Google didn't actually say when
their new chat bot or the new generative
search results would roll out so we
didn't get an answer on timing but what
about on look for people who've used
chat GPT before will this new Google
feature look similar well there's two
different products and that was
something they clarified today there's
Bard which is pretty much chat GPT
although they would argue it's better
it's it has access to information from
Google search for instance and then
there is a Google search product
something that would be in your search
results page for certain queries giving
you generative responses and so they did
give a little bit more detail about how
that would work you know it in certain
queries like if you ask a question that
doesn't necessarily have a right answer
like the example they gave was what are
some good constellations to look at it
will then draw from a diverse Ray of
sources to generate an answer for you
that's a little different from what chat
GPT does or even from what Microsoft
announced where you know you were able
to type in a kind of complex query and
it would compare different things from
Bing and give you an answer Google says
they're working on other kinds of of
search Technologies and products based
on this underlying technology but the
one today they talked about was this no
one right answer result page we've known
that Google has been working on AI for
some time can you tell us a little bit
about their broader efforts in this
field
well Google was mostly building AI more
quietly into its services like it was
improving its automated translations or
improving its understanding of your
search query so that it would give you
better results now obviously the public
interest has changed and the company is
talking a lot more about some of these
new products that it's rolling out and
the question many people are raising
some investors and even people inside
the company is well why didn't they put
out these products sooner yeah I mean
you've been speaking with experts what
do they say about this idea that Google
has maybe been caught on the back foot
when it comes to Bringing out an AI
product
I mean I think that there's a very real
impression that for the first time in a
long time there's a potential big
Challenger to Google search certainly
Microsoft thinks so Google's response to
that is well we are taking a very the
word they like to use is responsible
approach to releasing these tools
because the reality is that these kinds
of systems like chat GPT can as the word
is hallucinate if they don't have
information for an answer they will make
one up that might be fine if you're
asking it to write a haiku about Winnie
the Pooh but you know if you're trying
to like find out what medicines you can
take to cure an earache you don't want
it to give you the wrong answer and in
fact even Google's own Search bot Bard
in the announcement they made about it
Monday they had an image of Bard
answering a question the question was
what are some facts I can tell my
nine-year-old about the James Webb Space
Telescope and people really lies that
one of the bullet points it gave was
wrong it said that the James Webb Space
Telescope took the very first picture of
an exoplanet that is a planet outside
our solar system but there are images
that have been generated from telescopes
other telescopes long before the James
Webb Telescope was even launched Google
search executive in response when I
asked him that told me that this is
precisely the reason that these things
require rigorous testing and that's why
they won't give a time frame for when
these they're coming out apart from soon
because they're doing a lot of internal
testing and now with Bard some external
testing to make sure that they meet a
standard that Google thinks is
sufficient for their products we're
talking about we're talking about
Microsoft are there other company
trying to get into
search space you know you can't forget
about China's Baidu which operates the
big search engine there and they have
announced an AI powered chat bot that's
called erniebot that they say that they
plan to launch next month so it's
definitely a competitive space and I
guess what does all of this mean for the
future of the web and how we use it well
that's a great question and I think
Google would say that they're
responsible others might say slow
approach reflects concerns about that
because not only is there a question
about accuracy but there's also a
question about what are people using
search engines to do search engines
funnel a ton of traffic to other
websites news websites some of the
sources that are used to train these
large language models and Google today
at their event actually went out of
their way to say one of their concerns
is making sure that traffic still leaves
their website that you don't just read
the generated text on a search engine
and never click anywhere alright that's
our reporter Sam schechner Sam thanks so
much for joining us thanks so much for
having me and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing for more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]